Prime Time game shows
[Music]
military parades
and bookstores with dedicated sections
to the writings of Chinese leader Xi
Jinping
these are some of the ways China's
propaganda machine has elevated XI
standing to levels unseen in decades
over his 10 years as leader she has
tried to orchestrate the country's rise
as a global superpower despite the
recent slowdown in the economy and
pushback from the West he really has
overturned the way China has been
governed so as she prepares to secure a
third term as president we break down
these three moments along his path to
becoming one of China's longest serving
leaders
she joined the Communist Party in 1971
and steadily climbed through its ranks
over the next few decades in 2007 he
rose to the National stage when he
joined the polyp Bureau standing
committee a group of China's most senior
officials
party Elite actually was craving a
strong leader
[Applause]
when Xi Jinping came to power in late
2012. the party's power Brokers got what
they wanted and then some
the new leaders change and approach was
put on display right away when she
visited the city of Shenzhen to lay out
his vision for the country
and he chose a symbolic venue an
exhibition called the road to
Rejuvenation
in a highly orchestrated moment that was
broadcast on state TV she was surrounded
by some of China's most historical
objects the display told the story of
China's rise from subjugation to Triumph
under the Chinese Communist party's
leadership and here she unveiled the
name for what would be the next stage in
China's story with him at its home
China dream is a slogan that conveys XI
jinping's desire to make China a global
superpower that is equal to the United
States
in the early stages of his role she
tried to make China's economy more open
and driven by market forces he actually
laid out this very ambitious economic
reform program which called for State
companies to operate more like
commercial firms and for the government
to promote entrepreneurship he also
shattered taboos in Chinese politics by
targeting party Elders in a wide-ranging
anti-corruption campaign which ended up
being popular with the public he honed a
very personalistic Public Image as
shidada or big papa she
and she also challenged the us more
forcefully than his predecessors
she's territorial Ambitions in regions
including the South China Sea and
economic programs such as the Belton
Road initiative began to clash with U.S
interests
his China dream also meant putting China
on collision course with the United
States as China you know strove to be a
rival economically militarily and
politically
and this Collision was about to come to
a head when she invited president Donald
Trump to visit Beijing
I remember on Trump's first day in
Beijing Xi Jinping and his wife escorted
uh Trump and uh his wife on a private
tour of the Forbidden City
she's plan was to charm his rival and
calm the simmering tensions created
during his leadership
that China U.S relation
she didn't try to convince him that
there's still so much to gain from
having a good relationship with Beijing
but it didn't really work a few months
after the visit the U.S imposed a series
of tariffs and trade barriers on China
Washington said it was in response to
unfair Trade Practices and intellectual
property theft this began a trade war
that upended markets and reshaped Global
Commerce
trade War lasted two years at the both
sides cut a deal it didn't really help
improve the relationship the trade deal
was only a temporary truce soon after it
was signed the coronavirus pandemic
began sinking the relationship even
further this horrible thing that was
delivered by China and it was the U.S
president blamed China for unleashing
the virus a Charged Beijing vehemently
denied
the growing Schism between the countries
only made she look more powerful at home
as the man who had stood up to the U.S
and he ensured that he would remain at
the top by removing term limits in 2018
Paving the way for him to become China's
president for life he tried to roll back
China's decades-long Evolution toward
western style you know capitalism this
different past is basically
um socialism you know in the spirit of
Mao Zedong
[Applause]
and the spirit of Mao was on full
display in 2021 at the Communist Party
centennial celebration in Tiananmen
Square
we saw the TV footage of fallacy Japan
wearing this Mouse suit and standing
behind this you know Podium adorned was
a hammer and sicko
after a speech she sang along to the
international a socialist song that in
China has long symbolized Declarations
of War by the working class on
capitalism
and it soon became clear that this war
was being waged at some of China's most
valuable tech companies
private technology firms have grown
tremendously in recent years but
increasingly are seen as challenging uh
XI jinping's authoritarian rule
for she they were gaining too much
influence in areas like Finance
entertainment and digital gaming
it was almost like a 180 degree turn he
now is trying to further Encompass the
role of the state the government in
running economy but even as she has
continued to concentrate his power over
the past decade he's also faced
challenges from the pro-democracy
movement in Hong Kong to cover lockdowns
that have added pressure to an economic
slowdown weight by a battered property
Market
and as Beijing and Washington continue
to compete for Global influence she is
carrying on with his dream of making
China a superpower
as far as he is concerned China's time
has arrived